I would have lived my life very
differently
if I'd known these life lessons sooner
after more than two years of searching
I've compiled 365 lessons in one place
so you can use them in time to live a
happy regret-free life
if the path before you is clear
you're probably on someone else's
resentment is like drinking poison
and then hoping it will kill your
enemies
life is not a matter of holding good
cards
but of playing a poor hand well
be careful who you call your friends I'd
rather have four quarters than 100
pennies
beware of little expenses a small leak
will sink a great ship
whatever is begun in Anger ends in shame
he who laughs at himself never runs out
of things to laugh at
decision making like coffee needs a
cooling process
people are great at keeping secrets they
don't know
the only real mistake is the one from
which we learn nothing
don't judge each day by the Harvest you
reap
but by the seeds that you plant
if you want to get rich
think of saving as earning
be yourself
everyone else is already taken
life can only be understood backwards
but it must be lived forwards
great results can be achieved with small
forces
the roots of Education are bitter
but the fruit is sweet
Everyone Falls Down
getting back up is how you learn how to
walk
be silent or let thy words be worth more
than silence
spend your money on the things money can
buy
spend your time on the things money
can't buy
a busy man is seldom visited by idle
friends
no flies fly to a Boiling Pot
luck is what happens when preparation
meets opportunity
thousands of candles can be lit from a
single candle
and its life will not get any shorter
happiness doesn't diminish when you
share it
people never lie so much as before an
election
during a war
or after a hunt
those who have a why to live
can bear with almost any how
circumstances make man
not man's circumstances
there are two wolves fighting inside all
of us
the first one is evil
the second one is good
which wolf will win
the one you feed
a goal is a dream with a deadline
write your sad times in the sand
write your good times in stone
leave nothing for tomorrow which can be
done today
love your neighbor as yourself
don't judge your Greatness by your
Shadow at sunset
never interrupt your enemy
when he is making a mistake
a friend to all
is a friend to none
better a broken promise than none at all
both optimists and pessimists contribute
to society
The Optimist invents the airplane
the pessimist the parachute
a woman's guess is much more accurate
than a man's certainty
ignorance is the root and stem of every
evil
he who is not satisfied with the little
is satisfied with nothing
foreign
is like a shadow
on a sunny day run
you won't run away
on a cloudy day
look for it you won't find it
understanding a question is half an
answer
what we know is a drop what we don't
know is an ocean
be the change that you wish to see in
the world
Perfection is achieved not when there is
nothing more to add
but when there is nothing left to take
away
Simplicity is the result of maturity
never ruin an apology with an excuse
education is what remains after one has
forgotten what one has learned in school
it is not the man who has too little
but the man who craves more that is poor
the Journey of a Thousand Miles begins
with a single step
it always seems impossible until it's
done
how many things would you attempt
if you knew you could not fail
to get married means to have your rights
and double your responsibilities
that which does not kill us
makes us stronger
fear doesn't exist anywhere except in
the mind
you can't wait for inspiration
you have to go after it with a club
the life of the Dead is set in the
memory of the living
procrastination is the thief of time
color it
a leader is a dealer in Hope
you can't explain it to a six-year-old
you don't understand it yourself
we are not rich by what we possess but
by what we can do without
a friendship founded on business
is better than a business founded on a
friendship
as a child I pray to God for a bicycle
then I realize that God works
differently
I stole my bike and prayed for
forgiveness
there are one thousand lessons in defeat
but only one in Victory
when anger Rises
think of the consequences
whatever advice you give
be brief
one fate hands you lemons make lemonade
judge a man by his questions rather than
by his answers
your ambition is handicapped by laziness
the noblest work of God
man
who founded out man
be correct with everyone sociable with
many close to the elect friend to the
few
when you were born you cried and the
world rejoiced
live your life so that when you die
the world cries
and you rejoice
one day in retrospect the years of
struggle will strike you as the most
beautiful
where your fear is
there is your task
those who are hardest to love
need it the most
If You Can Dream It
you can do it
do not look for approval except for the
consciousness of doing your best
better to remain silent and be thought
of fool
than to speak out and remove all doubt
Success is Not final
failure is not fatal
it is the courage to continue that
counts
time stays long enough for anyone who
will use it
thinking is the hardest work there is
which is probably the reason why so few
engage in it
do what you can with what you have
Where You Are
we all love ourselves more than other
people but care more about their opinion
than our own
whatever the mind can conceive and
believe
can achieve
the Liar's punishment is not in the
least that he has not believed
but that he cannot believe anyone else
experience is the teacher of all things
an abnormal reaction to an abnormal
situation is normal behavior
the most important thing we learn at
school
is the fact that the most important
things can't be learned at school
one looking into a puddle sees dirt in
it the other
Stars reflected in it
a happy marriage is a long conversation
which always seems too short
any person capable of angering you
becomes your master
he can anger you only when you permit
yourself to be disturbed by him
there is nothing impossible to him who
will try
time passes slowly when you follow it
it senses being followed
thinking that someone else can make you
happy or unhappy is ridiculous
do not worry about tomorrow
for tomorrow we'll worry about itself
each day has enough trouble of its own
the oldest shortest words
yes and no
are those which require the most thought
courage is not having the strength to go
on
it is going on when you don't have the
strength
words can be like x-rays if you use them
properly
they'll go through anything
you read and you're pierced
through discipline comes freedom
of all the Liars in the world
sometimes the worst are our own fears
everyone sees what you appear to be
few experience what you really are
there are only three events in a man's
life
birth life and death
he is not conscious of being born he
dies in pain
and he forgets to live
a man who dares to waste one hour of
time has not discovered the value of
life
be kind
for everyone you meet is fighting a
harder battle
if your hate could be turned into
electricity
it would light up the whole world
do not spoil what you have
by Desiring what you have not
remember that what you now have was once
among the things
you only hope for
life is not a problem to be solved
but a reality to be experienced
tact is The Knack of making a point
without making an enemy
to put everything in balance is good
to put everything in harmony is better
live as if you were to die tomorrow
learn as if you were to live forever
only a fool learns from his own mistakes
the wise man learns from the mistakes of
others
a goal without a plan is just a wish
the future comes slowly
the present flies
and the past stands still forever
the highest activity a human being can
attain
is learning for understanding because to
understand
is to be free
who controls the past controls the
future
who controls the present controls the
past
appear weak when you are strong
when you are weak
time is money
if you wish to forget anything on the
spot
make a note that this thing is to be
remembered
everyone
at some time or another
sits down to a banquet of consequences
he suffers more than necessary who
suffers before it is necessary
education is the most powerful weapon
which you can use to change the world
fear of death increases in exact
proportion to increase in wealth
whoever violated trust once loses it
forever
life did not intend to make us perfect
whoever is perfect belongs in a museum
the reason why worry kills more people
than work
is that more people worry than work
everything that happens before death is
what counts
it is better to offer no excuse
than a bad one
men always want to be a woman's first
love
women like to be a man's last Romance
sometimes people don't want to hear the
truth
because they don't want their Illusions
destroyed
if you want to change people why not
begin on yourself
that is a lot more profitable and a lot
less dangerous
to be able to forget means sanity
the secret to success is to do the
common things uncommonly well
laws are like cobwebs
which may catch small flies
but let wasps and hornets break through
your enemies can kill you but only your
friends can hurt you
never close your lips Those whom you
have already opened your heart to
you can overcome bad habits only today
not tomorrow
to lead people
follow them
the first man gets the oyster
the second man gets the shell
it is better to make approximately
correct decision than to make a precise
mistake
never compete with someone who has
nothing to lose
gin
he bowled
and venture to be wise
stupid is the man who always Remains the
Same
if you're going to try go all the way
otherwise don't even start
no woman or man really knows what
perfect love is
until they have been married a quarter
of a century
the world belongs to the patient
seek wisdom not knowledge
knowledge is of the past wisdom is of
the future
the only person with whom you have to
compare ourselves
is that you in the past and the only
person better you should be
this is who you are now
if a man knows more than others
he becomes lonely
smart people learn from everything and
everyone
average people from their experiences
stupid people already have all the
answers
life is like riding a bicycle
to keep your balance you must keep
moving
things may come to those who wait but
only the things left by those who Hustle
success is stumbling from failure to
failure
with no loss of enthusiasm
He Who Walks straight rarely Falls
nothing is particularly hard if you
divide it into small jobs
believe you can
and you're halfway there
what we do now Echoes In
eternity
if you can't do great things
do small things in a great way
don't wait for the right opportunity
create it
people willingly believe what they want
to believe
the meaning of life is to give life
meaning
you can hide memories
you can't erase the history that
produced them
rules for happiness
something to do
someone to love
something to hope for
true woman loves a strong man because
she knows his weaknesses
she protects as much as she is protected
nature have given men one tongue but two
ears
that we may hear from others twice as
much as we speak
when we give someone our time
we actually give a portion of our life
that we will never take back
fiction is the LIE through which we tell
the truth
do not envy other people's good
qualities
but instill them in yourself through
admiration
who of You by worrying can add a single
hour to his life
do not say a little in many words
but a great deal in a few
if you want a thing done well
do it yourself
The Secret of Genius is to carry the
spirit of the child into old age
which means never losing your enthusiasm
knowing yourself is the beginning of all
wisdom
Gardens are not made by singing oh how
beautiful
and sitting in the shade
never was anything great achieved
without Danger
the most Exquisite pleasure is giving
pleasure to others
we stopped looking for monsters under
our bed
when we realized that they were inside
us
good people do not need laws to tell
them to act irresponsibly
while bad people will find a way around
the laws
what one man calls God
another calls the laws of physics
death does not concern us
because as long as we exist
death is not here
and when it does come
we no longer exist
I would rather be a swine herd
understood by the swine then a poet
misunderstood by men
it is nothing to die
it is frightful not to live
non-violence is a weapon of the strong
what we learn from history is that no
one learns from history
true love begins when nothing is looked
for in return
Who Dares nothing needs hope for nothing
no matter how thin you slice it there
will always be two sides
Victorious Warriors win first and then
go to war
while defeated Warriors go to war first
and then seek to win
love your enemies
for they tell you your faults
believe nothing you hear
and only one half
that you see
keep your fears to yourself
but share your courage with others
if a man knows not to which Port he
sails
no wind is favorable
lead from the back
and let others believe they are in front
wealth is like seawater the more we
drink the thirstier we become
and the same is true of Fame
if a woman is angry it means she is not
only wrong
but also
she knows it
love is an irresistible desire to be
irresistibly desired
learning to let go should be learned
from learning to get
real men despise battle
but will never run from it
yeah
we live in an age when unnecessary
things are our only necessities
he who has a why to live for
can bear almost any how
knowledge isn't power until it is
applied
how much money does it take to make a
man happy
just one more dollar
to be angry is to take revenge on
oneself
for the mistakes of others
any man can make mistakes but only an
idiot persists in his error
ask no questions and you'll be told no
lies
it is better to light one small candle
than to curse the darkness
he who is satisfied with his lot is rich
do more
the race is won by the horse that
outstrips its Rivals by a head
if each of us sweeps right under our
feet the whole world will be clean
a wise man gets more use from his
enemies than a fool from his friends
wisdom is not wisdom when it is derived
from books alone
an explained joke
is no longer a joke
the shortest distance between two points
is often unbearable
courage is resistance to fear
Mastery of fear not absence of fear
thank you did not shake the green apple
tree when the apple is ripe it will fall
down by itself
it does not require many words to speak
the truth
before you diagnose yourself with
depression or low self-esteem
first make sure that you are not in fact
just surrounded by
thinking is difficult
that's why most people judge
the way to get started is to quit
talking
and begin doing
anyone who has never made a mistake has
never tried anything new
If You're Going Through Hell keep going
if you always do what you've always done
you'll always get what you've always got
courage is not having the strength to go
on
it is going on when you don't have the
strength
do Every Act of your life as though it
were the very last Act of your life
the man who does more than he is paid
for
will soon be paid for more than he does
people who say it cannot be done should
not interrupt those who are doing it
a profession should initially be an act
of love
and not a marriage of convenience
women make even the men more
sophisticated
Above All Things Never Be Afraid
the enemy who forces you to retreat is
himself afraid of you at that very
moment
wealth consists not in having great
possessions
but in having few once
Fortune accompanies the brave
genius is a mind that knows its limits
drop by drop
is the water pot filled likewise the
wise men Gathering it little by little
fills himself with good
so in everything do to others what you
would have them do to you
do not chase after happiness
it is always in you
the best way to keep one's word is not
to give it
experience is not what happens to a man
it is what a man does with what happens
to him
what is a friend
a single soul dwelling in two bodies
he travels the fastest
who travels alone
it is better to act and repent than not
to act at regret
trying to forget someone means
remembering him all the time
there is nothing more unbearable
then idleness
there is truth in wine and children
the hard work of the future will be
pushing buttons
The Art of Living Well and the Art of
dying well are one
live your life as an exclamation rather
than an explanation
nothing makes a man so adventurous as an
empty pocket
the future depends on what you do today
the time for Action is now
it's never too late
to do something
only he who controls himself is free
if you want the present to be different
from the past
study the past
to know your enemy
you must become your enemy
well done is better than well said
a friend is a gift you give yourself
life is like a play
it's not the length but the Excellence
of the acting that matters
a winner is a dreamer who never gives up
who does not like loneliness does not
like freedom
anything you can settle with money is
cheap
you don't have to burn books to destroy
a culture
just get people to stop reading them
the one charm of the past is that it is
in the past
foreign develop success from failures
discouragement and failure are two of
the surest Stepping Stones to success
the LIE flies and the truth limps after
it
in times of war the law Falls silent
respect yourself and others will respect
you
no man becomes rich unless he enriches
others
without courage
wisdom Bears no fruit
manage your mood because if it does not
obey then it commands
to give out someone else's secret is
betrayal
to give out yours
is stupidity
we must bring our own light
to the darkness
when in doubt
tell the truth
don't let yesterday use up too much of
today
the best is always the enemy of the good
children learn by an adult's example
not by their words
first think
second believe third dream and finally
dare
a clever person solves the problem
a wise person avoids it
the thing you think about determine the
quality of your mind
most so-called failures our only
temporary defeats
life isn't about finding yourself
life is about creating yourself
men cheat because they don't feel needed
women because they don't feel loved
it's not what happens to you
but how you react to it that matters
often the lies that are believed become
the truth
in order to understand the world
has to turn away from it on occasion
all that we are is the result of our
thoughts
do not judge
where you too will be judged
equally indifferent to blame and praise
men are moved by two levers only
fear and self-interest
never put off till tomorrow the fun you
can have today
to lead an orchestra you must turn your
back on the crowd
learn first
teach later
he who builds on the people
Builds on the mud
marrying is not at all difficult
it is difficult to be married
treat your parents as you would like
your children to treat you
intuition is something that is ahead of
accurate knowledge
a man is but the product of his thoughts
what he thinks he becomes
what Paul says about Peter tells us more
about Paul than about Peter
even the finest sword plunged into salt
water
will eventually rust
by failing to prepare
you are preparing to fail
the Saints are the Sinners who keep on
trying
difficulties strengthen the mind
as labor does the body
intellect is invisible to the man who
has none
you may turn into an archangel a fool or
a criminal
no one will see it but when a button is
missing everyone sees that
anything you dream is fiction and
anything you accomplish is science
the whole history of mankind is nothing
but science fiction
women are meant to be loved not to be
understood
do the hard Jobs first
the easy jobs will take care of
themselves
live every day as your last
because one of these days
it will be
the greatest Victory is victory over
yourself
control your finances or lack of them
will control you
out of your vulnerabilities will come
your strength
if a man is as wise as a serpent
he can afford to be as harmless as a
dove
rule your mind or it will rule you
you are what you do
not what you say you'll do
any fool can know
the point is to understand
receive without conceit
release without struggle
progress is impossible without change
no man is free who is not a master of
himself
much is expected from that to whom much
is given
since we're all going to die
it's obvious that when and how don't
matter
do not dwell in the past
do not dream of the future
concentrate the mind on the present
moment
do not look back when leaving
10 people who speak make more noise than
ten thousand who are silent
the fact that people do not learn from
the mistakes of history is the most
important lesson of History
people in essence do not grow up
they only get old
he who wishes to be obeyed must know how
to command
the world is boring for boring people
the secret to being creative alone
ideas are born in loneliness
no gains without pains
compromise is the best and cheapest
lawyer
we learn not in school
but in life
a man only begins to be valued when he
is no longer there
when they give you lined paper
right the other way
you can never be overdressed or
overeducated
smile
today is The Tomorrow you worried about
yesterday
no wise man ever wished to be younger
a truth is not hard to kill a lie told
well is immortal
recognizing a problem is half the
success in solving it
you are not what happened to you
you are what you chose to become
problems cannot be solved with the same
level of thinking that created them
waste no more time arguing about what a
good man should be
B1
those who cannot change their minds
cannot change anything
it is unrealistic to expect people to
see you as you see yourself
a donkey loaded with gold will open the
gates of any Fortress
only those who can afford not to lie
are free
he can do anything
who thinks that he can do anything
Above All Things respect yourself
give a man power and you will find out
who he is
he who is to be a good ruler
must have first been ruled
life's biggest tragedy is that we get
old too soon
wise too late
to be everywhere
is to be nowhere
one can always be kind to people about
whom one cares nothing
keep busy it's the cheapest kind of
medicine there is on this Earth and one
of the best
nothing costs so much in life as illness
and ignoring an illness
genius is one percent Talent
and 99 percent
hard work
if it is not right do not do it
if it is not true do not say it
the more we value things outside our
control
the less control we have
when someone betrays you
it's because it is a reflection of their
character
not yours
a fool is known by his speech
and a wise man by silence
throw off your worries when you throw
off your clothes at night
one today is worth two tomorrows
our thoughts make us what we are
if you want to live a happy life
tie it to a goal not to people or things
difficulty shows what men are
true love never has a happy ending
because there is no ending
to true love
if you cannot have a faithful friend
be your own friend
great men are meteors designed to burn
so that Earth may be lighted
laziness travels so slowly
that poverty soon overtakes him
other people's stupidity never makes us
smart
genius lies in the ability to
distinguish the difficult from The
Impossible
the truth is putting its shoes on
please